is it
nevertheless surprising to you that we
have not destroyed ourselves with
nuclear weapons so the mutually assured
destruction that we've had for many
decades from somebody who studies
violence
how does that make sense to you well i
mean i'm surprised only in the sense
that um accidental the the the fact that
we have not had an accident yet
uh has been quite remarkable
yeah because all the accounts are that
we've come very close to having very
serious accidents where
people on either side of misread
intentions or or apparent launches and
so on
uh so yes i think it is remarkable there
is a
nasty
generalization that can be made that the
longer that
powerful states go
without having wars then the worse the
war is afterwards
and you know you can sort of see that
that kind of makes sense because
basically what's happening uh with these
tribal groups that the nations are at
the moment
is that
after a big war like the second world
war uh they established new kinds of
dominance relationships
and then
during the periods of peace
what happens is that
the
de facto dominance relationships change
because some nations become poorer some
become richer some become more
militarily powerful and so on generally
economy and military go hand in hand
so you know right now china
emerged from the war is a relatively low
status state and is now high status so
if these were chimpanzees you know what
would happen is that you would predict a
conflict because uh you need to have a
readjustment of the formal dominance
relationships to recognize the the new
in-practice dominance relationships
recognized by the economy in the
military
so the longer that you have of a period
of peace following a war then the more
these tensions of unresolved changed
dominance relationships build up
and the longer they take to occur then
uh the more
uh challenging uh are going to be the
conflicts that's a terrifying view
because we've been we've been out of
conflict for quite a bit that's right
maybe it's building up
so it's a scary view but on the other
hand you know things have changed hugely
with the
advent of nuclear weapons because at
least that conforms to
this psychology that is very clear in
other animals which is you don't want to
get into a fight if you are going to get
hurt
so that's the whole principle of mad
mutually assured destruction and it's
doubtless being why powerful nations
like america and
and russia
have not used their nuclear weapons
since 1945.
the you know so
if we can overcome the problem of
accidental launches
then maybe the fact of mad does fit into
human psychology in a way that means
that we really will resolve our tensions
without using them but
we haven't yet really faced that
challenge you know i mean the soviet
union collapsed because of uh the poor
economy
but with
china you know desperate to
take back taiwan
and
america shifting its focus on the
pacific
the potential for something going wrong
is clearly very high
so what's the
hopeful case that you can make for a
long term surviving a thriving human
civilization
given all the dangers that we face
well i i can't really exactly make one i
would just say that
we're talking about the dangers
obviously the dangers are there yeah um
but but what i would
sort of think about is um
the notion that
that surprises
come from all sorts of different
directions
you know and um i mean
you you're you work in robotics and you
know i can well imagine that
there will be advances in robotics and
in some way i can't even conceive will
somehow undermine
the
motivation for conflict
something about uh you know by the time
chips have been planted in human brains
and we're all instantly sharing
information in a way that we never did
before
will this change the nature of
uh human existence in such a way that
these conflicts uh get resolved so
remove the conflicts but keep some of
the magic the beauty of what it means to
be human so like still be able to enjoy
life the richness of life the full
complexity of life because you can
remove conflict by giving everybody a
pill
and they go to sleep right you still
want life to be amazing
uh exciting you know uh interesting and
so that's where you have to find the
balance
well it's
yes i mean it's all science fiction
stuff and and uh so how it's going to
work out totally unclear
um
i don't see any worry about the magic of
life disappearing i mean
first of all you somehow get rid of
males i think i think you really need to
get rid of males because males are the
source of
uh of of a major problem which is the
lust for power
uh and uh the resulting conflict but you
don't think the males are also a source
of beauty
and creation no no i mean i i i don't
have anything against males as you know
as individuals and that sort of thing
and and males have clearly done a lot i
mean they've been incredibly exploratory
and creative
and what they've done in
in art and music has been wonderful and
that sort of thing on the other hand
i'm not sure there's anything
particularly special and i i think that
probably females could do the same thing
just as well when given the chance
yes including the dark stuff i i mean a
partial part of me is not understanding
the
so there is
a evolutionary distinction between men
and women
but
i tend to believe both men and women if
you look out into the future can be
destructive can be evil can be greedy it
can be corrupted by power so if you move
males from the picture which are
historically connected to this evolution
of that we've been talking about that
women are going to fill that role
quite nicely and then it'll be just
the same kind of process not the same
but it'll be new
and
interesting
there's a there's a sense that the the
will to power
craving power committing violence is
somehow coupled
with the
with all the things that are beautiful
about life
that if you remove conflict completely
if you remove all the evil in the world
it it
it seems like
you're going to um
you're not going to have a stable place
for the beauty for the goodness like
there's always has to be
a dragon to fight
for the way if you look at human history
now you can say
the the reason i'm nervous about a sort
of utopia where everything is great
is every time you look through human
history when utopia has been chased you
run into a lot of trouble where again
sneaks into this evil this craving for
power now you could say that's a male
problem
but i just think it's a human problem
and it's not even a human problem it's a
chimp problem too it's life on earth
problem intelligent life on earth
problem so like it's better to um
not necessarily get rid of the sources
of the darker sides of human nature but
more create mechanisms that
the kindness the the goodness as
the goodness paradox your book
that that
is um incentivized
and encouraged empowered
well look i i don't think it would be
utopia if you got rid of the males
right
um and certainly females are capable of
conflict
i just think it's a gamble worth taking
if you could actually do it
you can certainly find females in
history who've done unpleasant things
but nevertheless
you know we have a very strong
evolutionary theory which explains why
males benefit more by
having conflict and winning conflicts
than females do
and
so
if we want to talk about reducing
conflict yes then
it would reduce it to get rid of males
now i understand this is a fantasy
and it it i think it's a fantasy that
people would be able to talk about
fairly soon because
reproductive technology is getting to
the point where
uh it's quite likely that
human females could breed without the
use of males
and so
there would be a sort of
a potential dynamic
if
everybody just agreed not to have any
male babies it's a it's a really
interesting thought experiment i will
agree with you that
if given two buttons one is get rid of
all women
and the other buttons get rid of all men
um
realizing that uh i have a stake in this
uh choice uh you're probably getting rid
of all men if i wanted to preserve
earth
and the richness of life on earth i
would probably get rid of all men i
don't know i don't think you have a
stake in it you know i mean
but you're saying that because you're a
man yeah but i don't see why being a man
should make you any more interested in
having a male future for the world than
a female future you know you've got just
as many ancestors who were male as as
were female
well my problem is i'll have to die
well that's going to happen anyway
i know but like i prefer to die tomorrow
not today you know i don't you know i
prefer to snooze hit the snooze button
on the whole mortality thing but it's
interesting but this is not suggesting
that males have to die in order to make
room for females it's just
you know you you all you have to do is
just say
don't let us have any more males born
interesting of course you know the
difficulty is that that because we're
tribal you know some country somewhere
would say well we're not going to do
that yeah and then guess what they'd
take over yeah because they're male so
that's why it's impossible to imagine
actually happening
uh you know what i'm gonna
i'm gonna take that and actually think
about it i don't know i'm uncomfortable
there's a
there's a certain kind of woke culture
that i've been kind of uncomfortable
with because
it's not women necessarily it's more
just
there's a lot of bullying i see
there's a lack of empathy and a lack of
kindness towards others that's created
by that culture so but you're speaking
about something else you're speaking
about
reducing conflict in this world
and looking at the basics of our
human nature and its origins
in the uh
evolution of homo sapiens and thinking
about which kind of
aspects of human nature if we get rid of
them will make for a better world
it's an interesting thought experiment
but it is only a thought experiment i
mean you know it's got no practical
meaning uh right now yeah and i take
your point that
um
you know males get a hard rap nowadays
uh in some ways because
uh the balance of
uh social power
is moving
uh
against
um
i mean you know quite rightly and in a
strong sense of course uh against uh all
the nasty things that males do
but
what people sometimes fail to remember
is that
life is very hard for males who
don't have the power
who
don't have money
who don't have
access to women
you know i'm sympathetic to
in cells
i
i'm not sympathetic
to them using violence
to solve their problems
but i am very sympathetic to the fact
that
it's not easy simply to be told by
um
well-off um
feminist
middle-class people
that you shouldn't behave like this or
you shouldn't feel like yes because you
do yes
that's who you are i mean that
in general just empathy and kindness
male or female i
have
i believe
will be the thing that builds a better
world and that
that's practiced in different ways from
different backgrounds but ultimately you
should listen to others and empathize
with the experience of others and put
more love out there in the world now
that hopefully is the way to reduce
conflict
uh reduce violence
and uh
reduce that that whole psychological
experience of being powerless in this
world problems to become the best
version of yourself
and that you know well no one's gonna
disagree with all those fine sentiments
right but that
yes but that's that's an actionable
thing is actually practice empathy
right
like
saying that um
somebody should be silenced or just like
this group is bad and this group is good
i just feel like that's not empathy
empathy is
understanding
understanding the experience of others
and like respecting it
i mean that that's that's what it
that's what a better world looks like
that's what the reduction of conflict
looks like
it's like as opposed to uh saying my
tribe is right your tribe is wrong
uh forget the violence and non-violence
part
that just that act of saying my tribe is
right that tribe is wrong removing that
from the picture that's the way to make
a better world like that's the way to
reduce the violence i think
um
not necessarily removing the people who
are
causing the violence you have to get to
the source of the problem i don't mean
the evolutionary source but
the just the
the mindset
that creates the violence is usually
just a lack of empathy
for others
yeah but you know i mean you can't just
teach that because there's our
evolutionary psychology
puts us in particular directions so you
don't think
do you think it's possible to learn
through practice to resist the basics of
our evolutionary psychology the basic
forces
yeah i mean
lots and lots of training you know lots
and lots of education
can do it the
the famously most peaceful society uh
that anthropologists have recorded uh
involves a tremendous amount of um
of teaching
uh including some punishment
you know it's a society in thailand
um you you have to beat it out of
children
to make them nice so there's carrot and
steak
you know the point is that
you do not find societies in which
people are spontaneously
showing the kinds of
behaviors that we would all love them to
show
it requires work it requires work
you